tudo bem é não tem como começar a
conversar com vocês sobre as mudanças
que aconteceram no nosso brasil sem
falar antes que independente dos números
que eu vou falar ou escrever
existe muita história
atrás deles então o convite que eu
queria fazer para cada um de vocês hoje
é para tentar enxergar as histórias as
pessoas que estão atrás de cada
estatística que toda hora aparece no
jornal nos últimos anos
na última década o brasil teve que
talvez tenha sido uma das maiores
transformações econômicas na sua vida a
renda mudou mudou de forma desigual
mudou de forma desigual porque a renda
dos mais ricos cresceu três vezes menos
do que a renda dos mais pobres
e aquele país que historicamente uma
estrutura de pirâmide social muito mais
gente na extrema pobreza do que ricos
viram o país construtor de losango
social com mais gente no meio da
pirâmide ea história desses brasileiros
eu vou dividir com vocês hoje mas não dá
pra entender essas mudanças não é
impossível entender o outro sem que
antes a gente consiga se entender
eu sou homem
eu sou branco
eu moro numa das maiores metrópoles do
mundo
eu sou a a terceira geração de
universitários na minha família eu sou
um privilegiado
e é impossível entender o brasil
para alguém que teve as condições e as
chances que eu tive na minha vida sem
antes de entender a minha condição de
privilegiado os brancos ganham mais que
os negros os homens ganham mais que as
mulheres
quem nasce uma grande capital tem mais
chance do que quem nasce no interior e
ter pais e avós universitários conseguiu
me dar antes de quem não teve isso de
que a primeira geração de universitários
aço da família um privilégio que eles
não tiveram condições de sair na frente
e isso é também fundamental para
entender quem é essa tal de nova classe
média que todo mundo aparece é no brasil
parece que as pessoas têm uma certa um
certo receio de como se vê como se
enxergar
levanta a mão pra mim por favor
na platéia quem é rico
quem é pobre quem a classe média
bom
a gente fez um recorte uma pesquisa
nossa enquete perguntou essas pessoas
que fazem parte dos 15 por cento mais
ricos do brasil e de pelo menos a
segunda geração de universitários como
ela se enxergava um por cento disse
eram de classe alta de 13% de média-alta
47% de classe média e quatro de cada dez
jura que são pobres
teve até quando foi divulgado isso num
jornal de grande circulação em são paulo
um cara que escreveu falando olha ontem
do jornal descobri que sou rico
só que não é só pobre sou pai de família
tenho três filhos
eu tenho lá colocar a colégio particular
paga por essa particular dos meus três
filhos convênio médico da família
inteira colocar gasolina nos meus dois
carros viajar para a disney todo ano
como é que vai falar que eu sou rico ou
pobre não sobra dinheiro para nada
porque aquele rico é sempre o outro
no brasil a classe econômica não é
classe social
então estamos falando de sociologia
estamos falando de economia são pessoas
que têm uma renda por pessoa da família
que varia de 338 mil cento e oitenta e
quatro reais por pessoa da família
não é salário e renda per capita e isso
dá na média uma renda familiar
somando a renda de todos da família e de
pouco mais de 1.200 reais há pouco mais
de quatro mil e quinhentos reais
cá entre nós isso é muito pouco para ser
chamado de classe média é pouco né
é pouco mas é médio porque é essa
parcela da população brasileira que têm
a média da renda do brasil
pode parecer pouco mas é o retrato de um
país desigual que quando a gente pega os
5% mais ricos que começam com uma renda
por pessoa da família de dois mil e
quinhentos reais o que deve ter gente
aqui que entrou achando que a classe
média e descobriu que é rico
impressionante
então é esse dado nos dá duas notícias
uma rua em uma boa ou ruim é que apesar
dos avanços que o brasil tem no brasil
ainda é desigual
a boa que nós o abilio diniz somos da
mesma classe econômica tá todo mundo lá
no topo da pirâmide de renda no brasil
enxergar isso enxergar o outro chegar
aonde a gente vem pra onde vai nos
permite entender de diferenças entender
a necessidade de ter respeito por essa
diferença porque nesse processo que
levou o brasil a ser um país que
diminuiu radicalmente a sua pobreza teve
como efeito colateral um grande incômodo
da classe média tradicional das elites
nacionais nosso país
eu tenho certeza que aqui ninguém jamais
falar essa frase mas talvez você já
tenha ouvido falar
este aeroporto virou uma rodoviária
tenho certeza que ninguém nunca falou
isso mas talvez conheçam alguém que já
tenha falado como se a culpa fosse da
classe c essa elite que está incomodada
tem uma visão muito própria sobre a
democratização do consumo no brasil 58%
delas acham que deveriam ser obrigatório
ter versão do produto pra rico e pobre
50% afirmaram frequentar apenas
ambientes com pessoas do mesmo nível
social do tênis 17% acham que pessoas
mal vestidas deveriam ser barrados de
entrar em certos lugares 26 por cento
são contra o metrô no bairro onde moram
porque acham que o metrô aumenta a
circulação de pessoas indesejadas na
região ou diferenciadas como se diz em
são paulo
apesar de que andar de metrô em nova
york é lindo e 17 por cento acha que
todo o estabelecimento comercial deveria
ter elevador separado de patrão e
empregado
e esses são os que admitem
e esses anos que admitem o primeiro
movimento que existiu dessa elite
tradicional com o aumento da renda e do
que alguns anos um novo mercado
consumidor foi tentar catequizar o
brasileiro que estava melhorando de vida
como se existisse um único padrão para
melhorar direito ele tem que ser
parecido comigo seguir os meus gostos
só que não rola
e aí nós entendemos que inclusão de
verdade inclusão de verdade não é renda
é respeito não é consumo é a busca da
igualdade
a diversidade em que esses brasileiros
cresceram ao longo da sua vida fez com
que se criasse um ecossistema econômico
que faz com que os hidrômetro que a
unidade de medida da periferia é a
capacidade de se virar na diversidade
fosse muito maior na periferia do brasil
e desce um novo sentido para o jeitinho
brasileiro que está longe de ser levar
vantagem sobre alguma coisa e está muito
mais ligado à capacidade de conseguir
transformar limão e limonada
vou dar um exemplo disso é claro da
popular estava atrasado
fui pegar esqueci meu crachá fui pegando
o crachá josé viu o telefone e fala
bonito e se o renato o céu porteiro
bonita e renato é o 66 senhor pagou por
ele
eu ganhei
não paguei pra nada foi fazer uma
palestra e e e ganhamos lá mas é
conquistar os 3 mil três mil e
quinhentos reais
tudo isso se o renato
o cliente bom enfim mas mas compensa
quando o megapix ontem na câmera dele lá
uns 8 10
só isso se o renato a tv digital de
bacana é não tem tv digital 10 como
assim
vai ver que o bluetooth também é muito
bom não é uma porcaria e começou faz pra
chaveca as menininhas num ponto de
ônibus em seu renato o que a seu renato
nunca viu lá uma moça bonitinho ouvindo
música no celular esperando o ônibus
chegou pra ele falou é ouvido que me
passa por bluetooth josé nunca fiz isso
olha não sabe o que é perder o renato eu
queria dizer ao senhor mas ainda bem que
sou ganhou e celular
porque se eu tivesse pago tinha sido um
péssimo negócio
e eu como a cinza
olha o meu aqui ele abriu a gaveta e
levou o hiphone dele o hiphone do zé tem
câmera de 20 megapixels tv digital o
bluetooth tão bom que transformou o zé
no reino da lotação e pasmem espaço pra
quatro chips e aí quando me falou isso
eu tava meio desconcertado e eu na minha
arrogância 04 simples pra que você tem
quatro boca pra falar pra casa pra minha
cara e falou que talvez fosse uma das
maiores lições profissionais da minha
vida
o renato eu não sei o que diz ou faz não
como é seu trabalho mas o que eu sei
mesmo é que sou não entende nada de
pobre porque o senhor tem de si só um
pouquinho de pobre senhora sabia que meu
celular pré pago como todo mundo lá do
bairro e que o bônus o pré pago só serve
para agregar de uma operadora para outra
e eu não tinha entendido até me mostrar
a agenda telefônica dele e na agenda
telefônica do zé
o nome da operadora virou sobrenome da
pessoa
josé da silva oi maria de lourdes tim
fulano de tal claro pra saber que chip
usar na hora de ligar
e enquanto gastar uma fortuna de celular
o zé se virava que quem tem pontos vai
falar aqui dentro de casa
quase todo mundo na rocinha também mas
lá eles rateiam pontos vai fai como
outros 12 milhões de brasileiros batem o
ponto do iff
eles fazem uma vaquinha narrativa onde
vai cada um só paga assim então a gente
vai pra subir lá e meu irmão vamos achar
o ponto joy fay não dá
então vamos entender esse novo
significado do jeitinho brasileiro
vamos entender também que se tem uma
coisa que mudou no brasil é o aumento de
oportunidades o que em poder ao cidadão
e dá uma liberdade de escolha maior para
eles
muda o sonho muda a perspectiva mas
muitos agentes disso que mudou o brasil
não foi a economia que mudou o brasil
foi a mulher foi a mulher que foi com um
mercado de trabalho muito mais do que
uma 50% a mais do que os homens
a mulher foi o mercado de trabalho mas o
homem não foi fazer a sua parte na
cozinha e cuida dos filhos
o outro lado que a mulher de alguma
forma de terminar o dinheiro do homem
ela passou a ganhar o próprio dinheiro
isso incomodou vários homens e fez uma
pesquisa com os homens casados e para
vocês terem uma ideia mais de 60% dos
homens casados afirmaram que ter certeza
que a esposa com possui algum dinheiro
guardado sem ele saber os outros são
iludidos
também mais de 60% disseram preferir de
mudar mudar de opinião para não ter que
brigar com a patroa
é aquela história de quando você casa
tenha decidido ser feliz outra razão
mas o que mais estava incomodando os
homens era as escolhas da mulher do
consumo mesmo por ele
então a gente descobriu que 53 por cento
dos homens casados afirmaram que foi a
mulher que escolheu a compra do
computador da família
eu não acreditei e fui visitar uma casa
um casal e perguntei pra eles que quem
tinha comprado o computador
ele também fala pro meu marido claro
também porque seu marido porque ele
entende muito mais de tecnologia do que
o nosso e é legal o computador que seu
marido escolheu é maravilhoso tem intel
core 2 duo 4gb de memória wi fi
bluetooth webcam integrada que não
entende nada sem ter alguma coisa eu
posso dar uma olhada no computador que
seu marido escolheu claro que pode
b pega lá para mostrar pro moço e
apareceu esse sujeito segurando o
notebook rosa que segundo ela quem
escolheu foi ele que bom nisso mas eu
queria terminar pra que ele não esqueça
que junto com todas essas mudanças teve
um conjunto de primeira vez na vida
dessas pessoas ea primeira vez é
complicada é o primeiro beijo
a primeira vez sendo a de bicicleta
imagina a primeira vez que se anda de
avião
no ano passado 8 milhões de pessoas
andaram de avião pela primeira vez e foi
uma dessas famílias que foi fazer uma
viagem pelo nordeste chegou no nordeste
foi para o hotel e no dia seguinte eles
vão fazer o tal do city tur que estava
marcado para as 8 horas da manhã às 8
horas da manhã
eles não chegaram ônibus embora o nosso
pesquisador ficou esperando esse
protocolo aconteceu sabe moço é eu nunca
fui tão bem tratado na minha vida
a gente chegou no
quarto do hotel de uma geladeira cheia
de comida e bebida para a gente tudo de
graça
ficamos vendo televisão até tarde perder
uma hora mas já dá tempo
acontece que quando eu e meu esposo
estava saindo do quarto meu esposo foi
colocar a mão na maçaneta ele uma
plaquinha escrito por favor arrumem um
quarto e um quarto está numa zona
tiveram que voltar para arrumar o quarto
então eu queria terminar com isso
isso mostra a diferença que ainda existe
no brasil
de repertório e essa diferença do que eu
contei aqui com o exemplo que seja nossa
pesquisa faz com que os brasileiros com
que os brasileiros não tenham na prática
as mesmas condições de melhorar de vida
se criou um mantra nos últimos anos que
é o tal do mantra da meritocracia
o que as pessoas esquecem de dizer é que
não tem mérito nenhum em sair 50 metros
na frente
não existe meritocracia ea igualdade de
oportunidade não existe meritocracia
quando na infância alguém come bem e
outro tem que sair na rua a pedir esmola
e ajudar a colocar dinheiro da casa
se a gente entender isso a gente
consegue de verdade transformar o brasil
de verdade
ninguém transforma ninguém ninguém se
transforma sozinho o mundo o brasil e
nós nos transformamos em comunhão muito
obrigado obrigado